oh wow whoa
reactions are amazing i love these guys
he's really hit getting hit by real jets
of sand right there
you know sometimes we finish these
drawings out to full color
very slick sometimes they're just we
need to get it done fast brandon frazier
is having to do all this acting
with nothing around him shall i tell you
what the big
deal is here
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video stick around at the end to see how
you can get a 30-day trial for free
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artists react
we are joined by a very special guest
today you guys might know nick well it
turns out his dad
has done a bunch of work in the industry
and is kind of a legit og dude
we are joined today by alex laurent i
guess you could describe him as an art
director
for visual effects yeah so that is
correct i am a visual effects art
director and concept artist as well
what kind of projects have you worked on
that we might have seen or heard about
well some of the more high profile ones
would certainly have been at ilm
i was there for eight plus years some of
the films you might recognize
were saving private ryan was one of the
first films i worked on
minority report digital was exploding
and it was the super exciting transition
time from
practical to the new digital what would
you describe
a visual effects art director as what do
they do so what a visual effects art
director does
is basically designing all the cool
effects that you see
and that includes creatures and
imaginary landscapes and
anything that doesn't exist and
rendering what it will look like
and these renderings are used as a guide
and a template and a blueprint
for a lot of stages of the approval
process what's in there
is that a mystery for later that's a
mystery box
i want you to be able to react that's
why they call it
react you must read from the book
are we are we getting mummified we're
gonna get mummified
we're getting mummified we are in
serious trouble
the mummy i think i was in like seventh
grade when it came out
and i really wanted to see this movie
like it kind of came out of nowhere
because like it's just the mummy it's
like that's like an old monster right
who's into this but you see the trailers
like this looks pretty rad
you know that it holds up people really
still like that movie you can't say that
about all of the
you know big tent pole effects movies of
the day but that one is
among those that seems to still have
appeal it was a lot of work
it was actually the biggest project that
i'd worked on at ilm at the time
so you pretty much art directed imotep
that's right that was one of the things
that
the director needed to have designed and
visualized
earliest was imhotep because that is why
he came to ilm
the question is why remake the mummy
well he wanted to have an answer for
that he wanted to say because this is
going to be like
no mummy you've ever seen we're going to
achieve this in a way that
does not look like makeup or costumes or
practical effects
so the design of imhotep went through
many many stages it was like a contest
everyone pretty much threw in their own
best ideas for the mummy okay and they
just it was so fun there
are all over the walls everyone's
different ideas and
i just i mean i lucked out that he liked
the drawing that i did
which was uh of course which was this
one oh
wow whoa so that's that's that's the
that's the first
that's the first pencil drawing okay
these reactions are amazing i love these
guys
yeah there you go that's in hotep stage
one it's like so
visceral here hold that yeah okay so
that was a pencil drawing scanned in
basically
there's a full body so red so this
was what got the approval from him as
far as the transparency
so as we said he had to go through
stages so this was this is so cool
so this was where we were pushing the
limit of grossness for an r rating
versus a pg-13 was
wormy bits around the eyes you got
eyelid guts
eyelid guts so these are imhotep's later
stages
as he's sort of reforming there we go
oh cool that became another iconic his
jaw
disconnects opens into this super scream
yeah and all the flies come floor
pouring out
part of our process back in the day and
it might be used sometimes now although
i have a feeling it's all digital now as
we would go to our
awesome model shop and have our awesome
sculptors sculpt us
models called maquettes oh we had our
model shop help out
because there's nothing again like
holding something in your hand
not staring at a screen all the time and
also for lighting
and textures we'll have a really
beautiful model made and painted
is this this is the opening shot to the
movie it is it is the opening shot
[Music]
it looks cg to me or maybe like two and
a half d i'm assuming it starts off 3d
but is there miniature
stuff here too it's just it looks a
little too detailed yeah for me to think
that it's 3d
so supposedly nick is in the shot right
yes
maybe rumor has that's right this is
that shot but you're in the mummy
yeah he's down there he's with uh some
kids and a dog oh i see nick he's right
there
i recognize nick but the the biggest
thing that stands out to me is the fact
that it doesn't look like any of the
people
are actually like in the original plate
they look added
what gives them away the people look
like they're filmed with the tripod on a
green screen
so as the camera is moving you're not
quite getting a subtle
rotational parallax shift on the people
it's almost like a bit of a billboard
cut out
you guys are pretty close but also
amusingly not in some ways
i i'm getting some really enjoyment real
enjoyment out of this okay
the sphinx the plaza the temple
buildings all of that
is miniature wow what's the scale here
like how tall is that sphinx
uh that is about four and a half feet
tall okay here is my
drawing of the sphinx and the
scaffolding oh cool
this is what informed the prop makers to
build the scaffolding on the sphinx in
the movie that's right you know
sometimes we finish these drawings
out to full color very slick sometimes
they're just we need to get it done fast
this is amazing so you designed the
plaza
yeah everything from the paintings to
the statues and the torch in the middle
that's
cool yeah any egyptian scholar would
look at this and go
that top piece that wasn't yeah
centuries later and they never did that
thing until that you know
like did you worry about like upper nile
versus lower nile like design
or define worry
my favorite times were visiting the
models being built because that's also a
thing you can go
physically see you walk around this
amazing thing they're building from your
drawings and it's just incredible to see
it come to life
adam savage worked in that model
department at ilm oh yeah did you work
with him did you know he
worked on no no adam adam and i go back
to this
you know the mummy and the money i
actually dropped
the model shop was incredible tory and
grant of course
and there was some bond that we had with
the model shop because we all worked
with traditional
tactile physical media i got to talk
about how the shot was even composed
and created so that wall there you see
and those soldiers on the sand
they were filmed in morocco that is an
actual ancient fortress wall
wow what whoa it transitioned from a
miniature to real footage here
yeah exactly i was thinking this was
also some more miniature stuff and so
what they did is
they basically did a incredibly thorough
track on the shot and then we took the
curve of the camera
from the moment the actual plate starts
and we extended it backwards
to create this smooth camera move that
then informed
pre-visualization that i did with
some of my previous artists in the art
department that was then used to
extrapolate for the model shop
the exact dimensions and scale we would
need to create
all of the structures so i tell you what
the big deal is here
if i'm remembering this correctly we
ended up filming the model
pretty much at almost a noon or early
afternoon light
and i believe that was all caused by
reversing out again from the live action
plate i think the director then
called for this change of lighting magic
hour
sunlight to the left sun setting to the
left pretty much a pretty radical change
of lighting direction
late in the whole process we'd already
filmed this miniature
it was already in the can as we used to
say it was way too late in production
to reshoot it so it was all up to the
compositing team to essentially re-light
this entire
bloody shot well and they did a
masterful job given the
short time they had and everything else
so you're telling me the compositor had
to go through and specifically
darken all of the highlights on the
front of the
front of the sphinx they left i believe
what you're seeing there is real that
edge light
side light on the on the screen left
side that is all real light i believe
but all of the front face that you're
seeing so darkened that was
that was all pushed and interesting okay
extremely controlled
i mean dealing with shadows can be a
surprisingly challenging process there's
no like there's no
automated way to do it you just brute
force it even today you just have to
like cut it out by hand and
or paint it in by hand like it's there's
no other way to do that that's right
in my opinion the 90s is the golden era
cinema
you know i'm sure there's still good
movies now but i think the second half
of the 90s
is the best movies i've ever been and if
you have any suggestions for visual
effects from the 90s that we should
react
to please leave a comment down below
[Music]
so another big part was imhotep's
ability to change into sand
and we spent a lot of visual development
time devising concepts for how that
would look
whoa yeah so this is again trying to
define
just in an image what level of subtlety
for directors approval
and for the effects team to start
wrapping their heads around how to do it
i didn't want it to feel like a face
pushing through a rubber sheet we wanted
it to feel
very organic it's not solid and locked
like a piece of plastic it comes and it
goes
you see it you don't see it and that was
a really hard thing to dial
and that also pushed the state of the
art in particle system
animation in the day so particles
basically what you're going to be doing
is going to be spawning points in space
and you can stick what's basically a
card onto that particle in other words a
sprite basically just imagine a little
card with
like an animation of a puff or something
like that on it and you just multiply
that 100 times
they created essentially an animated
mesh for the face
that was animated in fairly traditional
digital keyframe fashion to open up
and then they basically devised a way to
get all the particle emitters
to stick to like a surface emitter type
deal before that was
like before before it was called a
surface emitter or before that was
widely known
that's what was going on here these days
people tend to use something called
volumetrics you have voxels as opposed
to particles so a voxel is a volumetric
pixel
imagine taking a space and dividing it
up into thousands or millions of tiny
little cubes
and those cubes can have properties like
how much light can pass through and
that's how you can do dust these days
with voxels but it's a very different
system compared to particles back in the
day
and one of the things that particle
systems kind of miss that voxels have
is a more definite shape because you've
seen like thick smoke coming off a
volcano like that's like thick
to find smoke you can't do that with
particle systems you can do that with
fluid systems and voxels
whoa
that's what voxels would look like these
days this is the concept
of the face in the ground this ended up
being an iconic image for the film
because the studio and the marketing
ended up taking the face in the sand and
using it as the main poster for the
whole film
and again our wonderful digital team
basically matched it very closely
those were all practical air guns
he's really hit getting hit by real jets
of sand right there
[Music]
so those sand waves coming up is to hide
the transition to reveal
that you see coming up that's exactly
right you can really tell it's two
different 3d models too
yeah that just transition instantly when
the sound wave goes across
yeah this was one of those times where
the art department was pressed into
service to help the compositing team
with just elements i'd probably have
that texture for the sand
in photoshop already and i think i
basically took a layer or two and sent
it to the compositor and they then used
it as a displacement map perhaps
yeah remember it almost looks like it's
just the bump map texture itself is just
sliding sideways
everything else is saying the same but
it gives the illusion that sand is going
down the slope
this is a scene i've been wanting to do
on a react for a long time because it's
super impressive you'd probably be
inclined to think that those are all
people in costume
so all of these mummies fighting are not
real exactly right
which is insane yeah because you know
some of them start to step over the line
and we're like okay that's probably cg
but like that guy in front looks
completely photoreal
photoreal mummies in 1998 that's
so impressive but i'm remembering there
was a good deal of mocap i was going to
ask i'm wondering because
the animation of them like walking looks
pretty good
[Music]
that little kick he did when he jumped
over he does this
and the head evaporates into sand for
here i'm pretty sure
there was a whole team of stunt
performers but like let's keep in mind
brandon frazier is having to do all this
acting with
nothing around him it's almost got like
a slapstick quality to the animation
and that's what kind of like betrays the
realism a little that's not an accident
that slapstick quality you talk about is
very deliberate you don't want it to be
cartoony but you want it right up
against this line where this is supposed
to be
swashbuckling and fun and funny
in its own sort of gross way
so one of the things that i know the
director
stephen summers was hearkening back to
this is a tribute to
the master of visual effects ray
harryhausen and specifically inspired by
the
famous skeleton fight in jason and the
argonauts talk about a throwback
super impressive oh visual effects
history 101
you cannot ignore ray harryhausen all of
his work basically worked in a similar
way
he used a process called dynamation the
stop-motion animated puppets and inside
each one of them
is a metal ball and socket armature that
is posable very precisely so he animates
these skeletons one frame at a time
all of them together he has to track
every skeleton arm
raising and every leg that's coming
forward and every sword swing
the backgrounds you see are live action
plates that they have filmed on
locations and they are rear projecting
those onto
a rear projection screen in front of the
animation tabletop set so what you're
seeing there when the skeletons are
fighting the people
that's the frame coming out of the
camera yeah this shot alone would happen
over days
and so the idea that nobody knocks the
camera nobody accidentally knocks the
stand
that's hard i will say though that it's
a safe bet that the actors
doing those moves in those days were not
as experienced at
fighting against nothing shadow fighting
that it was really weird to them and
nowadays it's
probably something actors are much more
used to being asked so we can see the
connection
you can see the inspiration and the fun
thing is like a lot of it's still
very much the same it's still practice
your moves you're eventually going to
fight against nothing and also live in
your imagination sure there's no cap on
here but still it's
animators going in and getting to add a
little bit of extra once the recording
motions have been done
brandon frazier is not improving but the
animators doing the mummies
get to start improving once brendan
fraser is locked in what needs to happen
when
[Music]
is that a cg hand that's probably a real
hand i look like a real hand with
the mask on the paint yeah i've got a
story about that i'm tempted to say that
i had a hand
in designing it's okay you can do puns
here dad jokes okay
yeah they're all right yeah okay i was
particularly proud of this is the the
little mommy arm the whole thing where
he gets held onto the table and then
sword drops and a little mummy arm
coming out was literally your idea yeah
i can actually say that
yeah it literally was that's awesome
yeah
you are the one who saved his life you
can argue about how many effects digital
effects of the day
hold up today but at the time this film
represented a lot of
innovation in computer graphics this was
pushing a lot of tools and techniques
that had not really been
developed let alone matured at the time
guess what
it's ren's book recommendation time
because today's sponsor audible allows
me to share with you another one of my
favorite books
one of my favorite authors brandon
sanderson has a novel called
war breaker the story is pretty great it
converts to your expectations in a
really
fun surprising way there's twists
everywhere but what i want to talk about
today is the magic system because any
good sanderson book
has an excellent magic system and in
this one in particular the system is
called awakening
essentially every single person in the
world has this essence
this sort of energy that they can
actually transfer to someone else if
they choose
and people can actually accumulate many
of these essences they're called breaths
you actually breathe out your essence or
this energy and what happens is that
when you start getting more of these
you end up becoming more powerful you
start getting really random powers such
as
really accurate color interpretation
really perfect pitch hearing imagine
being able to just like
suddenly be the world's best musician
but even more so you can actually use
these breaths
to awaken objects what does that mean
let's say i wake in this shirt here and
i give it a command
to wrap around my arm and goes
no big deal but i can also command it to
grab someone
i can have it strangle someone not just
cloths what about little rag dolls
or swords that's right the coolest
character
in the entire book is a sword night
blood is the coolest name
it's the coolest sword it feasts upon
your soul if you let it
now i know what you're thinking this
sounds kind of weird but trust me
sanderson never fails to deliver an
epic storyline with a really cool system
you're gonna love it
get a few chapters in and you'll be
hooked trust me if you've ever gotten on
one of my book recommendations before
you know i don't lead you astray and of
course you can begin listening to this
book right now
on audible with your membership you get
a new credit to spend on a new book
every single month but also you get an
entire catalog the plus catalog
of a whole bunch of different titles
podcasts interesting originals that you
can get there's a lot there that's
included in the membership and you can
get
a 30-day free membership by going to
audible.com corridor crew or just simply
text quarter crew to 500 500.
these are my favorite segments to do
because i get to literally just tell you
guys to read some of my favorite books
this is this is the best
okay now watch as i morph cut into
nick's dad it's extremely rare that we
record an episode on this channel where
we get to hold in our hands actual
pieces of history you know we grew up
with this stuff it inspired us but then
to hold like the pencil drawings
for like the storyboards the intro of
the mummy in my hands
it's pretty special alex thank you so
much for joining us
it's a real pleasure to come on and sit
on the couch with you guys and go
through these troves of
nostalgia and effects history and i'm so
glad that this is an audience that
is interested that's the beauty of your
audience and you guys
you appreciate their place in sort of
history yeah so
how awesome to be able to share all this
if you guys would like to see more of
alex's art you can follow him on
instagram
at alexander laurent or you can go to
his website alex laurent.net
come visit we'll have links in the
description below if you don't feel like
typing it all in manually